let's take a little bit of a hiatus from
our more rigorous
math where we're building the
mathematics of vector algebra and just
think a little bit about something that
you'll probably encounter if you have to
have to write a three-dimensional
computer program have to do any
mathematics dealing with three
dimensions and that's the idea of just
the equation of a plane
equation
of a plane
in
r3 and you know what a plane is i mean
we live in a three-dimensional world and
we see planes all around us the the
surface of your monitor of your computer
monitor is a plane regardless of what
angle you hold it at so i can draw it
here in three dimensions
i can
let me do a little bit better job than
that so let's say that that is the x
axis
this is my y-axis
and then that's my
z-axis
and we know what a plane looks like
it looks something like that i'm just
drawing it in an arbitrary angle and it
goes off in every direction
now the equation of a plane and you've
probably seen this before
it takes the fun it's a linear function
of x y and z so it's a x
plus b y
plus c z
is equal to d if this is the graph of
that plane then that means that every
point on this plane every x y and z on
this plane so x
y and z every x y and z on that plane
satisfies this equation
now another way just this valid way to
specify a point or specify a plane is to
give you an actual point on the plane
so say look that's a point on the plane
so let's just say that the point
let's say that this is the point
x naught
y naught
and z naught different it could be one
of the instances of this point right
here but i'm saying this is another
point it's on the plane that obviously
by enough by itself isn't going to
specify the plane you could pivot the
plane around that point in an infinite
number of ways but if you specify that
point and you specify a vector that's
perpendicular to the plane
and i could draw it starting from here
but i can shift a vector wherever but
let me just draw it right there so if i
also specify a normal vector to the
plane
normal and i just used a word that i
haven't defined for you yet but when i
say a normal vector so n
is a
normal vector
n is normal or which just means that
it's perpendicular to the plane it's
perpendicular to everything on the plane
it's perpendicular to every every vector
on the plane perpendicular to i guess
the best way to say it i'll just say it
in very imprecise terms everything
everything on the plane
so if you have some vectors lying on the
plane
if i have some vector here let's say
that's lying on the plane if you imagine
the plane as a piece of cardboard that
yellow arrow i just drew it would
actually be a i would have actually
drawn that on the cardboard it's sitting
on the plane if this yellow vector let
me call it vector a then if this is just
some arbitrary vector sitting on the
plane and this is a the normal vector to
the plane we know from our dot from our
definition of a of vector angles that
this is perpendicular to this
if and only if
n
dot
a
only if the dot product of these two
things are equal to zero and that's true
for any vector that we pick that
actually lies on the plane so let's see
if we can use the this definition of a
of a plane if we can use the i'll call
it the you know the normal
or i'll call it let me call it the n
plus let me do it this way i don't want
to do the k the n
plus
some you know x
not y naught
z naught
definition
and if i can go from that
to just the standard
the standard linear equation definition
a x plus b y
plus c z
is equal to zero let's see if there's
some way where based on what we already
know and using this information that we
can do that so the way to think about it
this point this little blue point that
lies on the plane i can specify it by a
position vector
so i let me set some position vector x
naught to be equal to
so i'm going to find x naught to be
equal to
the scalar x naught y naught
z naught now i want to be very clear
this specifies the coordinate that lies
on the plane this vector does not lie
entirely on the plane it starts the way
i drew it right here it's starting at
the origin it's a position vector and
the way i drew it it's behind the plane
and it's the tip of its arrow sits on
the plane but this vector itself it's
not necessarily drawn on the plane it
this plane might not even go through the
origin while this vector does touch on
the origin it just specifies some point
on the plane similarly let me define
another vector i said this was some
other arbitrary point on the plane x y z
and so you know this could be this is
true for any point on the plane let me
define another vector x
and i'm going to define that as
x
y and z so once again like x naught the
vector x let me draw it right there
this vector x
does not lie on the plane it goes from
the origin it's a position vector that
specifies a point on the plane so it
goes from the origin and it goes out and
it you can almost view them as you know
if the plane was like a coffee table
that this would kind of be this these
vectors let me see if i can draw it
if this was the the flat surface of the
plane
that the vector x naught is going from
the origin to specify
some point on the plane and then the
vector x is also going from the origin
to specify
let me do it a different color
the vector x is also going from the
origin to specify some other point on
the plane right there i just took the
plane and made it flat so you see it
right along at the side if we're sitting
you know if you can imagine sitting
right at the surface of the plane and
then you can see that these guys clearly
do not lie in the plane but using these
guys i can construct a vector that does
lie on the plane
what if i have what what does the vector
x
minus x naught look like
x minus x naught
well i just drew a little triangle here
x minus x naught i'll do it in
i'll do it in this green color it'll
look exactly like this x minus x naught
will be this green line right here
right this is x
minus x naught
we could view x naught plus this vector
plus x minus x not is going to be equal
to x if i were to do it on this graph
it's going to look like this it's going
to be like this
let me draw it better than that
it's going to go from that point from x
naught the point specified by x naught
to the point specified by x
and it's going to lie along the plane so
this right here is x
minus x naught i know this drawing is
getting very dirty but you can see that
this is definitely lying on the plane
so this vector right here
must be perpendicular
it must be perpendicular to n
per
appendicular
to
our normal vector now
if my normal vector let me let's say my
normal vector
and so
this vector is perpendicular to this guy
right here it's perpendicular to the
vector n1 n2
and 3.
now using this information how can we
get to this type of an expression just
this linear equation of x y and z
well we know that
we know that n let me switch to a
neutral color we know that n
actually i didn't want to do this carrot
here and it's not a unit vector but
let's say n
so it's going perpendicular to this so
the dot product of it we saw that right
there we saw in the previous video the
dot product of n with this vector right
here
actually let me draw it you know i
already drew the plane sideways so i can
actually draw my n vector my n vector is
going to look something like this it's
going to be popping straight out of the
plane
and i can shift it over but it's always
going to be in that same direction but
it's going to be perpendicular to this
vector right here so
n is perpendicular to x minus x naught
perpendicular x
minus
x naught which means that their dot
product is equal to zero well what does
x minus x naught look like
so this is going to look like
this expression if i write out the
vectors themselves it's the vector
n one and two and three
being dotted with
well if i take x minus x naught that's
just
x the scalar x minus the scalar x naught
the first term subtracted and then the
scalar y
minus the scalar y naught and then the
scalar z
minus the scalar z naught and we know
that this whole thing has to be equal to
zero because they're perpendicular and
then if we take the dot product here
we take the dot product we get
n one
times x minus x naught
plus n two times y minus y naught plus n
three times z minus z naught
is equal to zero and you might not
completely recognize it but this is
you'll have to do a little algebra to
clean it up but this is
the form
a x plus b y
plus c z is equal to d
and actually i think i made a mistake
here this should be not 0 this is equal
to
this is equal to d this is the general
form for a plane in r3 for you know a
plane is just a linear surface and r3 i
should have written a 0 there so this
does take this form and if you don't
believe me we can do it with an actual
example so let's say we have
i gave you my normal i specify a plane
but i give you a normal vector and i
tell you that normal vector is the point
one three
minus two and i say that it intersects
the point
or a point that lies on the plane the
the normal vector and the point don't
necessarily have to intersect but let's
say for a point that lies on the plane i
have the point one two
and three and i say give me the equation
for this plane
well i would say well if i take any
other point on that plane so if i take
any other point on that plane
x y z
and specified by this vector
the vector that's defined by the
difference between these two is going to
lie on the plane right the this point
and this point lie on the plane so the
the difference between these two vectors
the whole vector will lie on the plane
so the vector so let me take the
difference so x
minus
x naught
is equal to
is equal to
x minus 1
y minus 2 and then z
minus 3.
i'm saying this will lie on the plane so
this is
this is on
the plane
and it's going to be perpendicular to
our normal vector
it's perpendicular to our normal vector
so if i dot
my normal vector
one three minus two
with this thing right here
with x minus one y minus two z minus
three i should get zero because this has
to be perpendicular to anything that
lies on the plane
so what do we get we get one times x
minus one is x minus one
plus three times y minus two
just taking the dot product minus two
times z
minus three is equal to zero let's see
if we can do a little bit of math a
little bit of algebra here to clean this
up a little bit
i get x minus one plus three y
minus six
minus two z plus six is equal to
zero
and let's see minus six and a plus six
cancel out and then i can take this
minus one i can add one to both sides
and i get x plus 3y
minus 2 z
add that one to both sides is equal to
1.
and there you have it
just by using the simple fact that this
is a point on the plane and this is a
normal vector i was able to use the idea
that this has to be normal or it's dot
product with any point with any vector
that lies on the plane i was able to get
this right here i didn't have to go
through this whole business right here
you could have just
used this formula right here you could
have just said
n1 is one times x minus x one i guess or
x naught i could call it so x
minus this one
plus n two three times y minus 2
plus
minus 2 times
z
minus 3 is equal to 0. and then if you
just did a little bit of math a little
bit of algebra you would have gotten
there so hopefully you find this
reasonably useful this is actually quite
useful if you ever have to
do anything that involves any type of
three-dimensional
mathematics and if you ever become a
game programmer this will be you know
there's thousands of other applications
but this is kind of a useful byproduct
of some of the formal mathematics that
we've been doing